so you put down let's say 150k you you
put down 150k cash and you get a million
dollar deduction oh my gosh so let's say
you're in California a million dollar
deduction is saving you 400 000 of taxes
[Music]
all right we're live what's going on can
I tell you about a cool rich people tax
credit scheme I discovered yeah so uh
actually a mutual friend of ours is the
one who put me on to this but um I won't
say his name because you know never talk
about another man's taxes uh so so
when uh when we sold the milk road I was
like oh man how do you
um you know reduce taxes in a situation
like this is there anything I could do
and I think we sold in October so it was
like you know
you get this windfall of profits in in
October is there anything between
October and December I could do to lower
taxes and I looked at a lot of different
options I what are the legal
clear
buy the book options that I could do
and uh when most people try to generate
large you know deductions or write-offs
they typically think of what a car car
because let's say you need millions of
dollars of of depreciation real estate
go for Real Estate so so real estate's
typically the one but um you've always
lazy and your boy doesn't like to go and
own things and have to like you know
manage Properties or anything like that
um you can always put your money with
somebody else and try to try to do it
that way
um but this is pretty interesting but
you still got to research all of them
and and yeah it's still a little bit of
a pain exactly and you have to buy size
so like how do you get you know let's
say you buy a tip a property you know
you're only going to be able to write
off like a portion of it right so you'll
get the the sort of the depreciation
that you can get the bonus or
accelerated depreciation if you maybe do
cost sag or something you'll get 20 or
30 of the value of the property to write
off but let's say you needed I don't
know what pick a number right let's say
you needed a 10 million dollars uh let's
say you're putting up you had 10 million
of taxable income
you would need to buy like a 30 million
dollar property or so just to be even
close to deducting like enough to make
it significant and that's a big deal
especially for somebody's not in real
estate so I was like okay that don't
want to do that and uh our friend put me
onto this thing he's like you know
there's this other form of depreciation
in the form of financing movies have you
heard about this no but tell me about
this okay so okay so here's uh by the
way it sounds like a horrible idea no
it's a it's a great idea I think I think
it's a great idea so basically
there's this thing called Film
Production tax credits and what ends up
happening is the following movie needs
to get made Let's just use some numbers
uh and by the way I'm not an expert at
this uh but I I get the broad stroke so
uh forgive me if I get some of the
ratios and percentages instead of Bro
Science this is bro tax yeah exactly
right
numbers no no words aren't my thing but
body language
so so let's just pretend you have a
filmmaker wants to make a movie for a
million dollars so in order to make a
film for a million dollars you need to
raise that money from somewhere and what
happened was there was always these uh
there was always these uh kind of like
depreciation incentives but when Obama
came came into to power he added to them
so what Obama did was he changed the
rules I believe during his time to say
you can write off a hundred percent of a
film's cost before they even make the
film before the money spent on that film
just on the budget so let's say say it's
a million dollar movie
if you buy that movie
you can write off a million dollars
right then and there nobody like you
don't have to wait for the whole thing
to be shot before you had to wait for
certain days of production in order in
order to write off those costs now you
can just write off from day one as an
incentive
to get people to fund more movies and
fund more art and culture and this sort
of thing because Louise aren't really
the best money makers so you needed a
little bit of an additional incentive if
we want wealthy people to uh to do this
so now what happens you put down let's
say 150k you you put down 150k of cash
and you get a million dollar deduction
oh my gosh so let's say you're
California a million dollar deduction is
saving you four hundred thousand dollars
of taxes so already you see the spread
right I put 150k in I save 400k in my
taxes
um now it gets better so where's the
rest of the money come from
so you need the other other 850k in
order to finance the movie you can go to
uh you know a bank get a loan for that
so you can go get loans on it you can
also get
um basically rebates in the form of
taxes so I don't know if you know this
but like most movies are not made in
Hollywood do you know where they're made
I think as of recently Georgia is that
right yeah Georgia Alabama basically a
bunch of States come and they say hey if
you got a million dollar movie we'll
give you 30 of the films uh we'll give
you 30 up to 30 in tax credits
and so you get it you basically you
don't need a million dollars to to fund
the movie you're gonna get get three
hundred thousand dollars from the state
in order to do it why does the state
want it right because State wants jobs
State wants if something's filmed there
and it looks cool that's you know
tourism maybe if you're let's say you
filmed in New York and you know looks
really glamorous now you get you know
additional tourism appeal you get jobs
and you get culture or art in your
community and you get business coming
there where otherwise who's going to
Georgia to do something cool right like
who's going to Alabama you know no no
shots fired at Georgia or Alabama but
but kind of
but it's human
so so basically that's so that now you
get funding on that side
which by the way you could just go sell
those credits you can just sell those
credits for 90 cents on the dollar if
you wanted or you could use them to fund
the fun the movie and so this collection
of things is part of a a a system that
wealthy people use in order to get
write-offs so what happens is there are
companies that throughout the year are
buying up rights to movies or scoping
out rights to movies like and they're
looking at it not in terms of like how's
the plot how's the script they're like
What's the budget I need a 1 million
budget I need a five I need a 15. uh
because I'm gonna I need options
available for my clients at the end of
the year so they basically hold options
all these things till the very end of
the year and then they go to their
clients they're like how much of a
write-off do you need oh you need three
million dollars cool here's a 10 million
dollar project we're gonna buy right
we're gonna put in this much cash we're
gonna get that much of a write-off we're
gonna Finance the rest and we can do
this as a group of investors not just
one person wait you're forgetting the
the the the second part and the more
important part which is the movie needs
to be made and make a profit
not necessarily the movie needs to be
made not necessarily needs to make a
profit so what happens the movie starts
to get made once it gets the funding
it's going to start getting made and
then they'll do things to help but what
you have to do is pay off the loan so
where am I gonna let's say in this
example of a million dollars we're gonna
pay off this 850k from well they'll get
the tax credits for part of it they'll
go sell the international rights before
the movie's made or they'll go sell an
option to Netflix and then they'll get
some Revenue in that way while the
movie's being made and they're using
that to pay down this loan so that you
get you know five years later when the
movie is finally made hopefully the
movie's paid off if it's not fully paid
off it's getting close and then you
basically have the revenue from the
movie once it happens and so it doesn't
even need to be this awesome you know 20
annual return because you got your tax
benefits five years ago
and so you just need to make sure it's
going to pay off the loan amount dude
this sounds like such a racket
where is there like a what that's
Hollywood baby that's Hollywood you just
get to say it that way does it mean that
it's less of a racket you know what I
mean just gonna say it's world's best
cup of coffee I mean it is it ain't
where uh where like what do you go to a
website you got a guy you got a movie
guy I got a guy now I haven't done it by
the way so I should say I didn't do this
last year because I learned about it
like four days before the end of the
year and then I was like what the hell
is this I was like we need to make a
movie baby I was like oh my God I won't
say his name let's just put his name
Charlie
hey I just got off the phone with
Charlie he's got a 10 million dollar
movie for me all right hey why are the
funds you know like it was a little too
too rushed um but the more I looked into
it it's a it is a legitimate thing it's
completely by the book you can go read
you know section 26 of the tax code you
could do the bonus depreciation of 100
of the film's cost in the in that time I
think the the key part is there's a
little there's some Nuance like just
like with real estate you got to be an
active investor so you have to be an
active film investor in order to offset
against your active income so you have
to like go to film festivals and do do
like 36 hours of film study online in
order to be qualified as active or
whatever the rules are I'm making up
those exact numbers but you know there
obviously is a lot of nuance to these
things but just broad Strokes pretty
interesting that rich people can hold on
a huge tax write-offs financing movies
so I'm just looking at this so you said
Obama did this or he like accelerated it
he increased it so that you could
depreciate 100
um so coincidentally the Obamas now have
a wonderful production company uh
beautiful Home In Georgia yeah
[Laughter]
it's called Higher Ground media and
they've made a handful of movies that
I've I've noticed or that I've seen but
they so if you go to higher
groundmedia.com they also have podcasts
so they are the uh so they have an
audible deal Michelle Obama did it used
to be with Spotify now it's with Amazon
audible they have the sum of us I don't
know what that is the big hit show
whatever they have all these oh they
have Renegades which is like this uh
Barack one so does this work for
podcasts is the question what's that
smell is that opportunity self-dealing
yeah
a little Barack special
uh do they does this work for by the way
he did it right man have you heard you
haven't you haven't heard of Pete from
Barack he he he's just he did this thing
he did an all right job he didn't
whether you like him or love him he
either did great or he did fine so he
did all right job and then he bounced
you know what I'm saying he just bounced
he's out and so he's hanging out with uh
Oprah and David Geffen on Manchester uh
on their yacht so he he did it right but
does this count for podcasts do we have
uh well I don't know my camera's on you
got a video over there that's a great
Point people would call I've seen in the
YouTube comments people consider us you
know a film a premium production
exactly I think we need to change the
the LLC name to premium Productions uh
and uh you're in Texas Texas not far
from Alabama we can do a little road
trip yeah that's interesting uh
hopefully this works for podcasts but
that's an interesting find I thought it
was stupid and it's actually more
interesting than I thought
how was your pod with repeat it was
awesome you want to do a recap yeah I
haven't listened to it so what's uh what
was the best part he made fun of you a
little bit uh he took a he took a a job
not at you well because there was a
podcast where I asked you if you could
get eight percent consistently but you
can't invest in anything other than your
own private business would you do it and
he was like Sean was crazy I was yelling
at the I was yelling at the screen
Furious that he wouldn't accept that but
he didn't actually give you a hard time
that was it uh uh he's very
um he's very principled which I actually
like I think uh you are the opposite not
I think you are one extreme and I
actually think I'm closer to you a
little bit than I am to him where he is
just like this is what I want I'm going
to do it and I'm going to do nothing
else like she's laser focused on a
couple things which I admire uh and then
he uh what is he focused on he was like
I can make more money with my business I
can duel I could I could have done a
podcast years ago but I just wanted to
wait until I felt it was the perfect
right time so he just calculated you
know you and I like to just throw little
things out there and see what catches
he's not so much that he also did a
really good job have you ever heard him
talk about the rich life yeah I've heard
him explain it's kind of like he made a
list of like what's the rich life to him
and then sort of use that as his
financial blueprint
exactly and he's got like a handful of
things like he's like I just wanted to
have the best assistant because I want
them to book Things perfectly so he's
like when I fly I try to fly on a very
specific type of airline with a very
specific seat so I want a certain plane
when I fly I want a certain type of food
ready for me when I arrive in my hotel
room and it was just very exact and I
love how exact he was it sounded like a
lot of work to set it up so I found it
intimidating but like he knew exactly I
hate people who are that particular I
hate people who are particular in
general I find uh it to be extremely
spoiled and snobbish
um you know I have like sort of sort of
like you are what you admire and I have
the opposite of admiration for people
that are extremely particular about how
they want everything managed and taken
care of in their life versus people who
are like look uh I'm blessed I'm gonna
roll with the punches you don't have to
cater to me
um I'm Gonna Make You know you could
serve me food I'm allergic to and I'm
gonna find a way to have a party in the
ER right like you know that is more of
the mindset that I admire is somebody
who is what I call unconditional meaning
their happiness or their mood is not
contingent on anything I find that to be
an absolute superpower and I I say this
because not to hate on roommate I say
this because I kind of only ever hear
about the opposite especially in this
kind of like
you know life hacking productivity porn
like kind of hustle culture type of
thing where
I think people get praised for being
super meticulous for being super
organized for planning out everything
for scoping it out for working backwards
all that stuff and uh I never hear about
anybody who's praised for being like you
know what this guy's always in a good
mood regardless of what's happening but
to me that's the superpower
yeah and I'm closer to you in that
regard like recently I went to a place
and I ordered a steak and they brought
me a pizza that was pesto chicken and I
didn't and I didn't I didn't tell like
yeah I didn't even tell my my wife was
like halfway through like didn't you
order a steak I'm like yeah but it was
here and whatever and so I'm I'm more
like you but I respect that he knows
what he wants and he wants and he and he
lives that way so I respect that and
then um Martin shkreli do you want to
talk about him really quick yeah we
never got to to debrief that so fun
pause I got a lot of [__] did you get
[__] I got a ton of black that we had
them on from where and dude just online
and friends were messaging me they're
like why would you give this guy a
platform and I don't think they even
listened to the episode because uh my my
response to why would you give this
person a platform it's twofold it's
number one
I'm like well did you watch the
documentary about him on Netflix and if
they say yes then I say well then he has
a platform did you criticize Netflix do
you know you watched it did you cancel
Netflix yeah like you watched Netflix do
you watch the news about him because you
he has the platform and second I'm like
how'd you like that Ted Bundy doctor
series pretty good huh yeah did you
watch that did you did you watch that
because that's the same thing and then
second I'm like well we actually did
challenge him quite a bit I think I
explicitly said uh why'd you act like an
idiot uh and why are you such an [__]
when you should didn't have to be an
[__] like we had a very productive
conversation I think uh and so there's a
fair criticism which is
he has an explanation about like you
know why how the healthcare system works
blah blah and we're not well versed
enough about the healthcare system to
know where to push back because like
let's say I don't know if he told us
anything that was incorrect or sort of
slight of Handy but if he did there's no
way I would have known because that's
not much right like
um you know it's like but why is that
wrong I don't know if that's wrong I'm
saying that would be a fair criticism
let's say you did know yeah and then
somebody comes on here they say
something that's either not true or sort
of misdirection or uh besides the point
or not really how things work
and the hosts don't push back on it it
can be very frustrating if you do know
and so I'd say that's a if if that's
what happened that would be I would say
a fair criticism on the other hand I
thought the most interesting thing he
talked about was just sort of like um
he's like I could be the Pfizer CEO
corporate speak
don't don't tell outside the line don't
give the media anything to get mad about
just quietly make your Millions just do
whatever you're gonna do right raise
prices uh you know whatever whatever it
is that you're gonna do it's not like
most pharmaceutical companies are seen
as like you know Angels but they don't
get the same level of flack because he
was very loudmouth he was very vocal and
he he poked the bear constantly and what
I liked was this moment and the thing
where I was like dude you're not dumb so
like you probably knew what you should
say or you had a person on your PR team
tell you at some point hey when you go
to Congress and they're asking you
questions don't be doodling you know
like a dog on your piece of paper uh and
and smugging you know having a don't
smile yeah don't have a smug look on
your face like he knew what to do
but he lives that troll life baby he's
like he's like I don't want to be that I
don't want a world where everybody who's
successful has to be this robot and I'm
gonna be me and I'm gonna have fun with
it and I'm gonna call bsybs I'm gonna
fight with people who don't know what
they're talking about
and I gotta say that is one part that I
really do admire about him and I think
somebody said this to me after the
episode they go you know you guys had uh
Billy McFarland from the fire Festival
on
and he seemed like a dumb like a dumb
cheat
they go Martin seemed like the opposite
he seemed like a genius cheat which is
basically like but you know Billy came
back he's like next thing I'm doing
another
fire festival or like actually and he's
doing it what he had said to us on air
was I'm gonna do this thing where you
could micro do so people are going to go
to this island and then you could vote
with micropayments to get them to like
snorkel with sharks and like we're gonna
jump up the water we're gonna jump up
the water if people donate and I was
like wow that's your comeback that's a
dumb idea but with Martin I would say
like uh you know I think you could
question whatever his ethics or um if
he's you know gone straight after
whatever you know what he did to to go
to jail
but I think it's hard to deny that the
guy's very intelligent and has a lot of
interesting things to say
um and you know frankly you can learn a
lot from from somebody who's highly
intelligent has interesting things to
say
yeah I you know what I was telling
people I'm like
I can like how Michael Jackson dances
and I can learn how to moonwalk from him
but also not like everything that he did
right uh you know what I'm saying so I I
can like both those things how's your
moonwalk um
um you know it's a it's a three out of
ten I'd say but uh I also there's one
criticism that we're starting to get now
that we're a little bit bigger that I've
been thinking about which is they're
like you have a responsibility to do X Y
and Z and my gut reaction is like f you
I don't have a responsibility I'm doing
whatever the hell I want but then I'm
like it is journalistically a bit and
that's like a really weird thing to like
uh kind of approach particularly when no
one got in for we didn't get into this
for that reason like we didn't want to
pursue truth we just wanted to have fun
you know what I'm saying yeah I think
that's
I mean to be perfectly clear we are not
journalists this is not journalism we
are not we are not reporting anything
this is me and Sam shooting the [__]
talking about business and interesting
things we see and then when we meet
interesting people we have them on the
podcast we have a conversation with them
and sometimes we like what they say and
sometimes we don't sometimes we buy what
they're selling sometimes we don't
sometimes we defend people because 95 of
people hate them uh but that doesn't
mean we think that they're perfect so
you know that's that's my stance on it
all right let's move on to something
else you tweeted out that um
you had nothing to say today which is
always great uh to hear I found a few
things last minute though
did you like my uh did you like my meme
yeah uh uh the Jesus meme I thought it
was wonderful it was uh it was a there's
like this famous is it Catholic I don't
know where it's like Prince in the sand
is the name of the story yeah whenever
you know we saw two footprints on the
beach or two sets of footprints and then
all one
well I bet if it's no it's then all of a
sudden I didn't see the second footprint
what happened and it was like that's
when I was carrying you son no it was
good it's like where were you when I
needed you the most if I were the only
one Footprints all right so do you want
to go first you want me to go
I'll go first really quick this is
something that I think both of us are
interested in but I have a feeling you
didn't uh you didn't care enough to look
into this because it was like a [__] ton
of reading but tiny our friend Andrew
Wilkinson he took his company public
it's officially public I think the
Friday I don't know what it is today it
was 750 million I think Canada which is
560 million USD somewhere between one
and a billion
yeah so hundreds of millions of dollars
and you know whenever you go public you
got to release a huge report and it's
300 pages and I read through a lot of it
and I found a bunch of interesting stuff
you want me to tell you some of the
interesting things
all right so the foundation for so
Andrew Wilkinson's our friend he owns
this thing called tiny tiny owns
either outright owns or partially owned
something like 10 to 30 things 30
different businesses
the whole thing started with meta lab
medalab was an agency that he created by
himself in 2008 and he basically made
websites it was nothing fancy at first
he made websites for Silicon Valley
companies but that's a little bit
glamorizing it because it was like
someone paid him like twenty thousand
dollars to make like a fairly
straightforward simple website then he
just kept going and kept going and kept
going well
it's listed in his uh I actually don't
know what this document's called uh in
America I think it's called the 10q uh
or just whenever they file for uh to go
public this company's in the I think
Vancouver Stock Exchange so I don't know
what it's called there but it's listed
as Digital Services Revenue in 2021 it
did 62.8 million dollars and that's
interesting because it actually has been
growing not crazy fast so it's been
growing something like 23 a year or for
the last handful of years we can only
see a couple years here but it does a 45
or 40 margin so for every 100 they make
their net income is something like 40 40
which is crazy now if you start in 2008
and you only grow 20 a year you actually
get to significantly higher than where
he's at now so there was years where it
was lumpy where it didn't grow or it
grew a lot and then it got smaller but
not significant of a business for
something that's been around for what's
this now 15 years and this has been the
foundation of everything
he has the CEO of that company and that
CEO has paid 1.1 million dollars uh
which is a good deal I think for
everyone so the CEO gets to run an
established company that's working and
they get paid a million dollars
um so here's something that's really
interesting if you scroll down to on
this document they have a list of a
bunch of the dividends paid since 2021
and if you add them all up it's
something like 15 million dollars that
he's took out of the business
um they took out a bunch more dividends
because they actually took down I think
something like a hundred million dollars
in debt so he he had a debt facility in
order to grow the company as opposed to
equity which is awesome because you just
take a loan and if that works it's
significantly cheaper than Equity if it
doesn't work it's that's not good you
owe a bunch of money but he did it and
it worked out but as he's been growing
he took money like 15-ish million
according to these documents out
additionally they had a company called
meal time which is like a meal prepping
software that he sold for 25 million
dollars so he had a and they gained they
profited 13 million dollars off that so
clay actively he's been making tens of
millions of dollars along the way super
fascinating while this business do you
remember you remember when we were
having lunch with them we're gonna have
to bleep out this number but do you
remember having a lunch with him and you
asked him some question you're like you
know
um at what number did you know life sort
of change for you or what what numbers
mattered in your kind of climb and then
he says he's like yeah
um
you know that's when uh that's when you
know blah blah and you go you go okay so
that's the net worth and he goes no per
year yeah if you go what we were both
like wait and then he skipped over I
told another story he's like yeah yeah
so like yeah every year and we were like
what the actual [__] is this guy talking
about you were making that much he's
like yeah
and now we see that it that it's all
like it's all on paperwork and and by
the way everything we're saying this is
strictly from the document where so
there's nothing else that we know uh but
yeah like he kind of killed it there and
then one last interesting thing is they
own this thing it's the company called
it's called tiny boards it's really just
wework remotely.com and it makes
um I think it's like six million a year
roughly
so it grew during you know 2020 to 21 it
grew from like 3 million to 6 million
then it went back down to like three or
four million but
I looked it up on LinkedIn I'm pretty
sure there's like three people yeah
very fascinating and they bought that or
they bought that from uh 37 signals from
Jason freed and dhh so that's pretty
cool yeah you know when so I invested in
this right before it went public so
private just privately and when I had
gone into that kind of the data room
um
I was looking around and I was like okay
so it seems like really there's kind of
like two interesting observations one is
he creates these like what they call
platforms which is basically means
you're gonna buy a bunch of the same
type of company so he has an agency
platform meta lab is the big one but I
think they have like seven eight or
seven or eight other agencies they're
just a lot smaller job there's like a
webflow agency there's a there's no code
agency there's a whatever agent yeah so
then there's job boards and they own a
couple of job boards then there's
creative tools which is like they own
dribbled and dribble block creative
market and cut and grew that way
and then they have whatever they have a
couple other then they have like this
like long tail of random things like
they would be funky the photo editing
app they own meal time they they own
some random things and I would say a
couple things really stood out to me
when I looked at it I was like
okay so you if you look at where the
bulk of the revenue and ebitda comes
from it's two companies so yes he's got
a portfolio of 30 companies
but it's meta lab and its dribble that
are carrying the thing on its back I
guess the other one would be uh we
Commerce which had split and gone public
uh which was a roll-up of Shopify apps
but that would have done pretty well too
I think and that one's at 25 million in
Revenue I think it was like something
like 10 million if you just look at the
eBay number sure I was like uh and I'm
not quoting this off I'm not looking at
the sheet but like just ballpark I
believe that we Congress ballpark was at
about 10 million in ebitda when it went
public
um I remember you saying that on the pot
that's what I'm getting that from the
second one is
um you know meta lab which you just
talked about you know let's say
50 60 million in Revenue 45 uh margins
so roughly 30 billion in ebitda and then
which is just a juggernaut and then you
have dribble and dribble does what
um does it have it for 30. so in 2000
yeah in 2021 so here's the numbers for
2021 Digital Services Revenue which is
considered agencies that was 63 million
creative platform Revenue which I think
is only dribble or it's dribble plus a
small thing in 2020 it did 23 million in
2021 it did 34 million and then they
have other which is all this small stuff
combined which was about 14. so just
those first two Digital Services which
is almost all meta lab
um you know the rest might add up to
less than 20 of that so if you just add
up 60 plus 30 plus 13 right this is
roughly 100 a little over 100 million
and 110 of that comes from uh medalab
and uh and dribble
and the ebitda on that I don't know
actually people are gonna laugh people
are gonna laugh at me I don't know what
adjusted ebitda Means versus just normal
ebitda but the normal ebitda which is
earnings before interest tax and
depreciation that was 50 million dollars
on that Revenue
yeah and you know what I think is
remarkable the amount of equity that
they put in to create this so now this
thing is valued at let's call it 800
million dollars right now 811 million
market cap right now
which is Canadian and it's I didn't
realize it's a 75 uh 25 decrease from
U.S church so let's say uh so it's that
comes out to be a little less than 600
600 basically so 600 uh 600 million
market cap company and I believe
uh he can confirm or deny this but I
believe less than 10 million dollars of
total Equity was put in so how much cash
did it take to start this business and
most businesses don't take a ton of cash
but um
but this is a this is an acquisition
based company so like you know they they
were acquiring companies and so I think
less than 10 million of seed Capital was
put in I could be wrong and the seed
Capital came from the profits of the
agency so in reality it's like he
started this as an 18 year old or 19
year old he said he was working as a
barista in the papers it has the stories
like I was working at a as a coffee shop
person and then I started doing this on
the side and it just we just kept going
and so the takeaway here is like simple
[__] it's it's hard but it's simple but
for since 2007 or something like that
amazing honestly kind of honestly it's
amazing uh and congrats it's amazing our
buddy Andrew for going public that's a
big deal you know uh that's a decade
plus of of hard work 15 15 years plus of
hard work
to get there so you know kind of amazing
for him I love that
any other takeaways you have
um no those are the those are the main
ones uh you know
I think you know one other thing that
Chris his partner told me at dinner was
I think I might have already shared this
on the Pod but he said uh when he got
hired and he met Chris at a bank Chris
was a banker uh literally like a like a
bank teller like I'd had a branch he met
Chris they hit it off about cars they
were talking about cars and um
because Android rolled up in a cool
looking car and Chris was into it or
whatever so they hit it off they ended
up talking for a little while he's like
what's your store what are you doing
he's like I'm starting to get my uh my
like CPA license like I want to be a
Finance person or accountant or whatever
and uh Andrew's like awesome I need help
uh my business meta lab is just getting
off the ground it's working pretty well
but like we're super disorganized come
work with me and uh Chris takes the leap
of faith goes to work with him he says
that on day one he's like I showed up at
the office
yeah there's nobody there uh like
Andrew's not there nobody's answer at
the door and then Andrew uh pulls up at
his Uber or whatever his car uh I guess
there's no Uber back then but it pulls
up in a car taxi hops out and he's like
opens the trunk takes out this giant box
full of paper and he's like here here's
all of our like numbers financials like
this is where it's at
um you know make sense of this and uh
and help us get organized he hands up
this huge box he's like oh by the way I
gotta go so I'm not gonna be able to
train you right now
um and there's no room in the office for
you so I talked to my neighbor they have
like a basement you can sit at their
desk in there and he's like just knock
on the door and tell him you're the guy
and then they'll let you into the
basement desk or something so he tells
the story how you started whatever he
gets it organized and as they're looking
at they're like all right
you have a very profitable agency
okay what do we do with these profits
right we're just going to like accrue
them that doesn't seem very good and
they're like well what do other agencies
do and they're like they looked around I
see in other agencies like all of a
sudden there's a giant ball pit in the
office there's a basketball court
they're flying you know fancy everywhere
they're hosted you know just basically
spending money on like
like status stuff or like appearances
and he's like we shouldn't do that that
doesn't seem to have any Roi
um right like adding the ball pit to the
office doesn't yeah it makes it more fun
but like you know I don't think that's
the best use of money what if we just
thought of ourselves like a really
profitable Law Firm and like you know
what if we were a boring business what
would we do with this money well we
would just go try to find a place to
reinvest this what if we take this
business that's okay agencies aren't the
best business but we use it to buy
better businesses and then that was kind
of like the conversation that they had
and that's where they started going out
and acquiring other businesses using the
profits for metal lab but there's two or
there's one part of that story that
you're missing and and this is because
it's probably not fun for them to tell
but they will tell it because they blog
about it which is they actually started
other things so they did the same things
that we make fun of and that we've done
as well they started a to-do list it was
called flow uh and they he said he spent
like four or five hundred thousand
dollars or maybe even close to a million
a lot of money of the profits and they
created this thing which was basically
like Asana but different and he goes
Asana crushed us because they spent way
more money and then they started I think
one or two other things I think another
thing called ballpark so they actually
started things right away and it failed
and then they go yeah let's just buy
them and that's what they did and they
still start things like super cast or uh
he's got a bunch of different ideas he
started since but if you just look at
him in the grand scheme of things it's
almost like a big company right it's
like they have the innovator's Dilemma
it's like this business is at one
million in Revenue in nine months it's
like cool who cares you know that's one
percent you know I didn't move the
needle this year but probably took a lot
of Creative Energy and recruiting and
promoting to get to to get to that level
so you have a tough thing where you
enjoy starting new things so you want to
do it you keep having new ideas but it's
hard for those new things to really
break out and make a difference
um you know and most most new things
generally will will fail or or not go
exactly to plan either so it's it's a
tough tough balance I think to have
and I know what they paid for dribble
and
um do you think I think you know too but
we can't say it do you think that uh you
can buy companies like this like is this
one of those things like you know or am
I just being a noob here where people
say oh you can't start a newsletter now
there's too many new newsletters I'm
like no that's not true but do you what
do you think about the competition now
to buy companies versus 10 years ago
yeah certainly more but there's also
more Supply right like uh the number of
like interesting
you know interesting internet companies
in 2007 versus 2023 is going to be
obviously like many fold more because
the internet has just become so dominant
there's so many businesses that are
successful so many playbooks of how to
build a good SAS business or a good
Marketplace or whatever
having said that is probably the type of
business where
you make one good decision one good deal
a year or two good deals a year and that
was a great year and um that I think
that speed is just very hard for most
entrepreneurial people to go out right
well yeah I agree with what you said
this is pretty inspiring and awesome so
that's the lowdown on Tiny good stuff
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated whoa I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
can we talk about I see you have
Harvard's revenue on here I have an
interesting story about Harvard's
Revenue so I want to hear your take yeah
I was doing some Friday night research
and uh as one yeah got to thinking how
much money is Harvard making yeah I'd
like to tell you some things about
Harvard
so Harvard is this thing that
um if you really like zoom out are you
like an alien and you're looking down at
Harvard
and you're like what is that thing on
the map yeah no no not be you the other
one you know what's what's over there in
Boston what you would see is basically
some combination of a church a hedge
fund and a luxury daycare and I'd like
to tell you about each of those
components and how Harvard is basically
this multi-billion dollar tax-free
Juggernaut all right there's a lot of
taxes in this episode yeah all right so
buckle up okay so how was it a how is it
a church well universities are tax
exempt so they don't pay taxes they
don't pay it on donations they don't pay
it on tuition room and board or even
capital gains from their hedge fund
which is the second part so they have an
endowment that's about 50 billion
dollars that they invest across a wide
portfolio I'll tell you their portfolio
in a second so they got a 50 billion
dollar hedge fund they have uh their tax
exempt on the gains for the Hedgehog
plus all the revenue from their students
well I should say revenue from their
luxury daycare because parents will pay
you know 50 60 70 000 a year to send
their child to this place for four years
and so they take your kids off your hand
for four years and they say you're
they're gonna come out in a better
better place and so here's some of the
numbers around this this mashup
juggernaut
uh last year
um 5.8 billion in total revenue
2 billion of that comes from the profits
of their endowment hell of a year for
them
um but actually this wasn't last year
this was I think 2021. so uh two years
ago uh so 5.8 billion in total revenue 2
billion from their endowment
1.2 billion from education so what that
means is 80 of the revenue is coming
from not education that's the other way
to look at that
um so where does the rest come from so
they have the endowment you have a
billion dollars of Grants so the
government funding research for their
professors 500 million of donations and
300 million from so you'll go pretty
well which is their publishing arm I can
tell you all their their in-house media
company so a couple couple observations
here
the school earns more Revenue than both
Twitter and Snapchat Twitter is at 5
billion Snapchat's 4.66 billion uh
Harvard has more Revenue than both of
them and it's been doing that since when
was Harvard created in the Harvard's
like 100 plus years old I think and so
it's been doing that forever not forever
but it's a very long time
amazing business right uh the publishing
arm makes 300 million dollars just
selling case studies to other business
schools and Publishing the hbr the
review journal which is basically a
really fancy paid sub stack it's got 350
000 subscribers who pay for the hbr the
Harvard Business Review but the majority
of that Revenue I think I can try to
find it but I study this a lot I think
that a lot of the so if we go to Harvard
Business School they uh they release all
their they break it all out and so if I
read it here so 34 of the so their
revenue actually went down 2019 it was
900 million in 2021 it was 800 so 34 of
that is whatever you said 300 comes from
publishing the next thing down is 14
came from tuition and of the of the 34
for publishing most of it is from
selling I think it's like they've sold
like they sell like five million case
studies a year to other business schools
yeah which is which is insane and the
Harvard Business Review has a lot of
revenue from International so here's the
other kind of like dirty secret from
from Harvard which is that they make a
ton of money off of Executive Education
464 million dollars so almost like
not quite half but like you know almost
half of the money they make from their
degree their actual school they make on
Executive Education which is basically
you pay to get professional development
credits AKA you get to put Harvard on
your resume without actually having a
Harvard degree if you go to Tyra Banks
remember Tyra Banks
yeah that's right uh
if you big T for sure if you go to uh uh
her LinkedIn it says
Harvard Business School and then like
you have to scroll down extension you'll
see you'll see parentheses and you'll
say I'll say extension uh it's a very
classic technique right my cousin did
this he went there and I was like whoa
we're going to Harvard he's like I'm
going to a I'm taking classes at Harvard
yeah taking classes at Harvard so you
you got into Harvard
uh yeah you know like sure I got into
the Executive Education Program at
Harvard and uh and he's like yeah like
you know on my resume it says Harvard
and he's like you know one out of three
people understand what it is a two out
of three dollars I like my eyes yeah
there's also the international arm their
International Revenue is up like 80
because they're selling the age of the
Business Review over there they're
selling uh you know Executive Education
come on come to come to America come to
the best part of America come to the
Louis Vuitton of uh of Education right
so basically
you got billions in Revenue zero taxes
owed huge barrier to entry a brand
that's lasted over a century the
government loans your customers money
and gives you grants for your r d like
what a business
dude that's absolutely crazy and a lot
of people don't realize this
um and to put these numbers in
perspective let's just say that so you
said their endowment I'm just doing all
this math right here um so I might be
off but I bet you if we Google it this
will be true if their endowment is 50
Public math are you well yeah I am sorry
but if they're in debt but it might be
wrong if their endowment is 55 billion
dollars
um it can and their expenses some years
I just Google it right now is around
five billion dollars that means
theoretically there are some years that
they can pay or charge their students
zero tuition and pay for everything
still the way that the endowment works
is it's a 50 billion dollar issue
endowment and there the plan is they
distribute five percent of it a year
so five percent of it a year is used but
the the the the the rule is this the
domain needs to last forever so they're
only going to distribute five percent
because they need the other 95 to stay
in and keep rolling and in 2022 when my
portfolio was down like 45 they lost 1.8
percent
somehow lost only less than two percent
when the whole Market has been terrible
this year here's here's their portfolio
by the way
three percent cash
okay 32 into hedge funds
which headphones does it say it doesn't
say which ones now 44 into private
Equity plus Venture Capital but most of
its private Equity so what do they buy
so that's the bulk of it
um and then there's six percent real
estate three percent bonds five percent
treasuries and six percent foreign
equities okay so what's this private
Equity stuff uh is does that mean
they're in like PE like like Blackstone
livestock or whatever BlackRock
wow dude this is like a circle jerk to
the max everyone's hands full on this
one this is crazy right because
yeah because you if you think about it
like if I look up where the hedge fund
guys went I bet you know 70 of them went
to Harvard I mean this is just it's
pretty it's a very circular thing going
on here it's pretty wild like it it is
it's I would say it's almost corrupt and
if you think about 50 billion a 50
billion endowment that's bigger than I
than I would imagine 95 of countries GOP
I mean it's like that's massive
Gob
uh GOP that's the uh what's that the uh
the Republicans what's uh GDP yeah but
and yeah like you know we think these VC
funds like Sequoia and Andreessen are
like really big like I don't know what
injuries it's total AUM is but I'm
guessing it's like between 10 and 15
billion uh it ain't 50. yeah
yeah exactly 50 billion and they're I
think I mean they're they're okay
they're now at 35 they've been scaling
it up like crazy uh but that's our
full-time job that's their thing yeah
that's their thing this is just like you
know I I would imagine there was a I
forget what I was watching but there was
some show where it was like a lot of
people don't realize this but like
venture capital and PE like the biggest
when people I always hated when people
celebrated a venture capital company
going bust like uh what was that one guy
who uh the the Disney guy who went
started uh the thing that quibby you
know it raised like billions of dollars
and went and it went bust what a lot of
people don't realize is this money for
so the money that is given to Andreessen
Horowitz into this and that it comes
from the universities it also comes from
the California's teachers pension plan
or the the police pension plan or
firefighters or and like you'll like I
think if I remember correctly I I
believe like Nevada for some reason I
think it was like the state of Nevada
for their pension plan for government
government workers something like that
had one of the best uh returns and they
was basically like one dorky guy and
he's pretty much just like Warren
Buffett you know he has a similar style
or um a similar budget where he has all
this money and he just would sit in this
office and except unlike Warren Buffett
he's getting paid by the state and so
there was a story about how he was
making you know a nice amount of money a
year but he would bring brown paper bag
lunch and he just drove before Windows
95. yeah yeah and he's like look I'm on
the uh and and this guy was like a
fiduciary a fiduciaries where he was
like I don't waste taxpayer money and
because of that I read all this stuff I
very rarely make big bets and but when I
do it [__] crushes it and so like
these guys Chad yeah he's great and he's
like and so anyway it's just like these
guys making these decisions they're just
government workers in a way but they're
making they're basically mini Warren
buffetts and so it's really fascinating
like the world of these like endowments
and these people I met a guy once who
worked for Alaska's Permanent Fund I
don't know if you know about this day
have 79 billion in assets under
management so Alaska has all this money
from the oil stuff or whatever and then
they give everybody who lives in Alaska
like three grand a year or something
like that which is basically like well
you know when people were talking about
Universal income they're like oh that
sounds crazy I'm like you know they do
that in Alaska I think I think you get
15 grand a year if you live in Alaska
right
yeah I don't know I thought it was like
maybe three four but yeah maybe it's
more um but yeah there and then there I
met a guy who manages that that money
and he's just like what was he like I
mean he wasn't the main principal but he
was a guy who worked there
and he was like he was at the farming
conference and I was like what are you
doing here and he's like I'm looking for
you know intelligence and then and
Investments you know Farmland is a great
investment and I was like Wow uh good
for you this is uh you know who would
have thought this guy's managing way
more money are these people manage way
more money than like the famous kind of
hedge funds or um or Venture capitalists
that you hear a lot about dude I wonder
if this topic is interesting Ben let me
know in the slack because I like I'm
geeking on this stuff I found this to be
crazy fascinating
um so he's typing now um you want to do
one more thing yeah let's do one more I
have a quick idea my nine my nine okay
so uh
sounds a little bit sick uh last 24
hours I don't know you have a great
haircut by the way though I really like
the uh the uptown fade you got you know
high fade it's the uptown fade with the
downtown brow
[Laughter]
I just wanted to say something cool it
looks good you look sharp have you been
have you how much weight have you lost
in the past three years
um I think I've gained weight in the
last three years I just changed the
composition like I uh you're looking to
put on a lot of muscle too much muscle
um in a way that's like not good like uh
not like it's like I'm not neither a
bodybuilder nor am I ripped I'm just
thick and thick is like I don't know
anybody who puts thick on their vision
board like some people do I mean look at
your your right arm right now or
something dude your right arm right now
I definitely hit you with a little I
definitely see you try try yes I see a
great teardrop man that's a that you
gotta get a good tricep muscle that's my
uh what do you call it like your your
highlight your Keystone asset that's my
Keystone your tries thank God it's in
the zoom view yeah imagine if my quads
were what was good I'd just be wasting
it every day Welcome to my life my
friend
yeah you should make an excuse to stand
up every day every every episode just to
you know Flex on them a little bit yeah
no you look good you definitely looks
felt uh and people in the comments are
saying it but sorry go ahead uh well I
mean that was great anytime you only
take that tangent and we can go there
um all right so I was I I was in a fever
and I had a little fever dream I thought
of an idea that I'm pretty sure would go
viral I'm not gonna do it but um
you know our friend
um Nikita who has created the same app
twice and sold it twice to the same to
similarly stupid tech companies that
that didn't realize it's like just like
a nothing app oh you're talking about uh
Nikita the [__] beer
that's an official name right for those
who don't know Jimmy Cooper but it just
stands for douchebag Cooper
yeah I know Nikita the [__] beer you
know the funny thing is he's got this
Persona online of being kind of like a
[__] poster and like kind of a [__]
but usually when you beat those people
the if you ever meet somebody like that
you're like what's what are they like
it's like dude total sweetheart love
that guy totally not like you see online
no you know how like you know that's a
very common thing where you're like oh
you know Sean you know saying whatever
oh yeah great guy great guy
I don't know if that knows that phrase
may not be used with him is he getting a
great guide he's not getting very good
yeah
oh he gets a wow
that's him so anyways The Genius of what
he's done because undeniably created uh
you know these like really viral teen
apps is his app works as follows you
download the app
if you take a quiz that says who in your
school or who in your contact is most
likely to whatever and to try to figure
out in your contacts who you talk to the
most or whatever so that they could
surface maybe the right person in a
multiple choice so that you you say Sam
is is the guy who I'd want to bail me
out of jail and at the end of the thing
it's like wow those are awesome do you
want to know what Sam says about you and
you're like yeah for sure and basically
it texts you in the background and it's
like Sam
someone said that you would be the most
likely person to bail him out of jail do
you want to see who and you're like of
course click download you take the quiz
and that's the viral Loop
do you remember back in the I think I
have another one of these uh do you
remember back in the day the Myspace top
top eight I think it was called it was
like uh was that like who was in your
top eight friends yeah you just got I
mean this was
this is just like a pretty wild concept
to be honest with you you just put on
your profile
yo these are my top eight friends in
order
which is like I don't know that today
that'd be considered like you know
bullying to the 10th degree but you know
I think where that came from was like do
you remember blog rolls or it was like
if you would go to a Blog and it would
say like um here's who else yeah on the
right hand side you would list like
eight other blogs that were similar to
you that you were friends with which by
the way I thought was awesome I always
like I go I try to find whatever a great
way to discover things yeah I love doing
that and then a lot of people don't know
this but Tony Shea the founder of Zappos
he created what was it called it was
called media link I think and it
basically went from zero to like a 400
million dollar acquisition and all they
did I think originally it was called
link exchange is what it was called is
they helped broker the deals where
eventually it was a pay-to-play for like
the blog rolls which is like the things
on the side and I think that is where
Myspace kind of got like this idea of
like here's like my top eight or
whatever like here's the people I to
help you discover new people right and
you know Tom from Myspace would always
be your your automatic number one when
you start and then you have to fill in
your friends and it was this awesome
thing you could go to someone's profile
you could be like oh they're best
friends with this person oh this girl
moved to number one maybe they're dating
it was like this little like this like
signaling thing and it was cool it was
felt so good to be in someone's topic
and it felt so bad to be out of
someone's top eight so but it lets you
know where you stand and there's
something I really appreciate about that
so I think you can recreate that now
with something I'm calling my nine and
what my nine is you download this app
and it just says
who are your nine people who who you who
you rocking with and you just designate
of my contacts these are my nine and
they let you publish that as a photo to
Instagram or as a video onto Tick Tock
or whatever it just lets you share that
out just saying hey here's my nine and
you tag them and it texts them also from
your phone and somebody puts you in
their their my nine
do you want to see who and of course
you're going to download of course
you're going to sign up to see who
you're going to connect your address
book and then you're gonna select your
nine and you'll reciprocate because
that's what people do and so I think
this would also go super viral
because I think it just has those like
human psychology triggers where if
you've got that message you got to know
who did it and then when you're there
you'll do it too because it's kind of
fun like a little personality quiz and
then that triggers the next nine invites
that go out and nine invites is enough
to go viral so like even if you have a
15 conversion rate of which this would
have like more like 40 probably
um you will by definition your K Factor
will be over one you will you will go
viral dude I always wanted that for when
I die
you know like my nine for when I did I
might die I die my die so like I've I've
always wondered like if I die how is
anyone gonna know because like when you
I imagine this sounds douchey 100
Tombstone just here's my nine friends
top of my friends
I don't know again I'm gonna preface
this it sounds douchey but when you
start having a little bit of something
you eventually you have so many
different accounts and like there's
companies that I've invested in and I
[__] forgot when I when I sold the
hustle we there's this one guy he uh
what was his name Jonah uh he started
moat.com and he sold it for like a
billion dollars he's just a rich guy and
he gave me very little money enough that
like he probably makes that a day in
interest and when we sold it took me a
year to get in contact with him
I swear to God it took the lawyers were
like dude we cannot get in touch with
this guy like his because he sold his
company so it's like he just we can't
get in touch with them we don't know we
gotta give him his money but he's owed
money it's just sitting here and
I'm not close to that but there are some
Investments that I've made that I've
forgotten about and I've always wondered
like if I die how is anyone in my family
gonna know like who get like where this
stuff is or if they're who are they
going to contact am I like is there like
a like a like a like a next of kin like
checklist you know what I mean and it
changes all the time too so even if you
wrote it down once
This is Gonna Change I actually don't
know how this works when you die how do
they discover all your assets especially
not with like crypto or Angel Investing
I don't know I'm gonna discover all this
stuff and who are they gonna have to
contact because particularly with crypto
it's a lot of single young guys like
who's like the next the next of kin for
that I have no idea you know there's do
you watch succession hey this is
producer Ben quick note Sam is about to
drop a massive spoiler for the HBO
series succession so if you plan on
watching it and you're not all the way
caught up skip ahead like two minutes
enjoy they're like he he just left
everything to this emoji
yeah dude on succession it's like a you
know the thing it's basically Rupert
Murdoch's family and the the Rupert
Murdoch character dies and they find his
will and he wrote it in pencil but they
and they there's this part where he's
giving stuff the company to his son and
they can't determine if he's crazy yeah
well no they couldn't determine is he
Crossing out the guy's name or
underlining the guy's name because he
like it was like a crooked line like is
he Crossing it out or underlining we
don't really know what that is but I've
thought about that I'm like when I die
if I die and my wife dies at the same
time unless that we don't have kids
whatever I'm like how are who are they
gonna know to contact it like they got
to figure out where my mother lives like
it seems like an ordeal you're gonna
have a really rich dog yeah I guess uh
so they need my nine but like that's
like now like you took this in terms of
like a uh a trusted will solution yeah
my teenage viral app idea yeah my nine
probate is what it's called and it's
just like you really uh yes I ended that
one he went full improv kid on that one
and took it to an only place dude I've
just been thinking about that have you
not thought about that because like
there's some [__] that you've probably
done it could be small like every once
while I'll like just do a deal like I'll
just invest like five grand into
something and I don't tell anyone about
it like you know you and I you and I
were joking five grand is about the
limit where you like tell your spouse
that you're doing it and like you know
there's been things that I've done like
oh I don't even [__] remember I guess
there's a scratch-off ticket that I won
somewhere I have no idea
dude um yes I've thought about that
especially with crypto but then when
crypto crashed I was like hey never mind
forget it forget what I told you it
doesn't matter anymore
you know those instructions I told you
about how like you know it's written on
this fireproof you know platinum card
that's stored in this safe in this
foreign country yeah forget about it you
don't need to go retrieve it anymore
particularly with crypto it seems crazy
um so I need my nine but for my will God
damn
I guess that's the part
did I I meant to
be a Yes Man on that one by the way not
uh not uh yeah you did all right good
that's good all right uh is that the pod
that's the pod
[Music]
foreign